depuis le début de notre scolarité on
nous parle du pacs et le bail par si la
la la c'est le bac partout c'est pour le
bac travailler pour le bac à la fin vous
aurez le bâcle diplôme tous les profs on
parle tout le temps on ne risque pas de
l'oublier
[Musique]
bonjour donc moi ça d'elle j'ai 18 ans
je suis en terminale s au lycée jean
xxiii aux herbiers je m'appelle hélène
je suis élève en terminale s au lycée
les bourdonnières à nantes il m'appelle
et les chiens en terminale scientifique
au lycée valin à la rochelle
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons garantir de façon
absolue la tenue d'épreuves écrites au
regard des conditions sanitaires
l'ensemble des épreuves du brevet et du
baccalauréat général technologique et
professionnel sera validée en contrôle
continu
on va passer
[Musique]
nous étions dans une forme de stabilité
en ce sens qu'on avait des habitudes
voilà pour les lycéens ils allaient
terminer leur année ils allaient passer
le bac avec plus ou moins d'anxiété et
après il allait aller chacun dans son
bref l'avenir était relativement tracé
aujourd'hui tout cela éclate ne pas
passer le bac ça reste très frustrant
étant donné qu'on est formaté et que
depuis le début de notre scolarité on
nous parle d'une pac
c'est frustrant de d'avoir ça en tête de
nous en parler tous les jours pendant
trois ans donc c'est l'objectif c'est
clairement l'objectif est que il est
plus d'objectif donc c'est ça peut être
frustrant même si moi je sais que ça a
été puis soulageant qu'autre chose je
suis à la fois soulagé pas passer le bac
parce que c'est vrai que j'avais
j'appréhendais l'emploi ce que j'allais
avoir 18 ans goisses et d'angoissé bon
je vois la tonne de ce que j'avais à est
visée il avait du boulot quoi beaucoup
d'élèves voit un peu cette année comme
une année blanche
étant donné qu'on n'a pas passé le bac 1
bun des profs clé est emblématique qui
montre à la fin de notre scolarité et le
début de nos études supérieures c'est
quand même symbolique le bac on
connaîtra pas ce que c'est de voir les
résultats de tout ce qui passe à la télé
on connaîtra pas c'est sûr je suis quand
même déçu parce que je me dis que bah
c'est notre objectif de tout notre
scolarité sont là sans rien faire entre
guillemets il n'y a pas vraiment
dangereux tant que notre boeuf on l'aura
pas dans nos mains on ne leur a pas dit
ok t'as ton bac il s'en passer les
épreuves
bah c'est difficile de se rendre compte
après est ce que tout un avis après on
va nous dire bon bâton bay qui compte
pas parce que c'est un bac en contrôle
continu donc c'est pas un remake
[Musique]
on s'attendait pas du tout à ce que ben
si on se retrouve au cloître et chez moi
prêt à réviser tout seul travailler tout
seul et on a quand même été de mini mars
à mi avril dans la tente de savoir
comment ça allait se passer pour le
baggy nos profs nous ont beaucoup
entouré et encouragé durant cette
période on a pu le remarquer en parlant
rien discutant avec eux toute cette
classe que leur prof était beaucoup
moins présent que dans notre classe
c'était un peu stressant voyez le fait
d'être tout seul et de diabate alba qu'à
la fin de l'année mettez tout seul à un
peu préparé quoi et c'est resté un peu
mais après par contre quand on a su
qu'elle ait pu avoir le bac et surtout
contre eux continuent bel à la
motivation un peu chuté tout de suite il
ya un relâchement toute émotion qu'on
devrait avoir acquises et clairement je
pense qu'on les a que survoler
[Musique]
après ses études supérieures et ça ça
fait un peu peur pour beaucoup d'élèves
qui ont décroché ça peut être très
difficile de reprendre des études
étant donné que là ça va faire je pense
que si on reprend pas les lycées en juin
cela fera six mois qu'on n'aura pas eu
cours je pense que ce sera un peu plus
compliqué que si on avait eu cours
jusqu'à la fin d'année surtout que le
bac c'est quand même des épreuves qui
nous apprennent à vraiment révisé soi
même j'appréhende la reprise parce que
je me dis que l'ajustement on est plus
habitué à se lever tôt à faire des
grosses journées cours le retour à la
normale ça va être compliqué même si on
est tous dans le même bateau de cette
période elle aurait été quand même
bénéfique parce que ça nous a appris à
utiliser des nouvelles méthodes pour
travailler comme par exemple moi je sais
que j'ai beaucoup lisez mon ordinateur
pendant cette période alors que je ne
l'utilisais pratiquement pas pendant le
lycée et ça m'a également appris et pas
qu'à moi en parlant avec toutes ses
lettres je sais que ça nous a appris à
gérer notre temps j'ai pas peur d'avoir
deux lacunes ou quoi je pense qu'on a
tous hâte d'entamer notre vie
personnelle vie étudiante
j'ai aussi hâte de travailler ahmad de
faire des études pour moi qui
m'intéresse et d'arrêter d'avoir une
pression par rapport à ce bac je vais
partir en nicole de metting la première
année commune aux écoles de médecine est
donc là je sais vraiment que fera
l'armée travaille mais vraiment manière
très intense donc j'en ai conscience et
je me dis que là bas ça permet à nos
ressources et de
c est que l'année prochaine je vais
pouvoir toulouse
[Musique]
j'avais d'adieu ya pas eu de fin il ya
48 main on est allé ce dernier vendredi
encourt aussi d'immenses croissante de
trois semaines la fin du confinement
et puis et puis là on est deux mois
après et puis ben
c'est pour bientôt
[Musique]